foreign
let's go to Steven in Ontario what's up
Steven
hey John how's it going partying dude
what are you up to
not too much just enjoying the day
um is it one in Canada right now how
cold is it
I'm all it's actually been pretty warm
this winter it's it's about zero right
now normally be at minus 20 Celsius but
uh it's been a warm one this year so
I don't even know the words you just
said man I don't understand but I don't
understand you all right what's up
uh yeah so I got a relationship question
for you today okay bring it so so for
some context uh I've been in a
relationship being my girlfriend for a
bit more than a year now and uh it's
been a great relationship uh very loving
uh great communication I couldn't ask
for anything better
and after some
internal reflections of thought and kind
of sitting with the feeling for a bit I
think that I am ready to
start having a more serious conversation
about looking at
what next steps might be in terms of
Engagement and kind of planning more
seriously what life together might look
like cool now hello how old are you
uh I'm 24. I was hoping you were gonna
say 16. okay 24. all right cool this
would have been way more fun if you were
16 but okay so 24 awesome
so what's your how can I help
yeah so the the one thing I'm really
considering with this is that while I
very much have sat with this feeling and
kind of
thought that a lot and
do you really feel it
I think that
you know it's been just over a year and
uh it might be kind of more prudent to
sit with this feeling a bit longer you
know yeah a few more seasons of Life
under our belts and more experience with
life beside each other before kind of
stepping forward with something like
that and is kind of dealing with the
conflict of I very much really do feel
that feeling of I'm ready for that next
step but also kind of bringing myself in
a bit and just saying hey like times on
our side and we're pretty young and let
these feelings kind of continue to
deepen and sit with them for a bit and
just kind of get your thoughts on that
yeah man thanks for the call
um I think first and foremost you need
to take your feelings and flush them
down the toilet
I think you are being led around by your
feelings
and if you set into a long-term
relationship now like make no mistake
like you feel in love and you feel super
you know like all jazzed up to be next
to her like all that's cool like feel
they're awesome right
they make great road signs they make
terrible directions
okay like
because here's what's gonna happen
you're gonna be four or five years into
this thing you're gonna be married
and then she'll have a kid and you'll be
figuring X and Y and then you won't
quote unquote feel it anymore
I've been married 20 and a half years I
can guarantee you the feelings come and
go
and at some point if you if you heard my
conversation with Jordan Peterson I made
a covenant I said I would and the times
I have been dangling over the edge to
leave this thing and to walk all that
I've been held back by that one I said I
would
said I would
and so
feelings are fine and good especially at
the beginning
when I begin to look for over time is
are our values as we know them right now
aligned
right and we we've very much had has had
those conversations and over time at
overtime increasing kind of complexity
and kind of seriousness like and kind of
we've definitely I think has come to the
conclusion that our values very much do
do align but uh I think it's kind of
sitting with each other and kind of
living those values out and kind of
getting consistency over time with that
man you're you're running this thing
like it's a computer program and it
doesn't work like that okay
because my my first impulse is to say
yeah you could go through a lot of life
rigamaroos and experiences and do all
that dating
but that's the stuff that makes
relationships really remarkable and
strong
that's the stuff that you get to share
with other people when you've you're
committed when you're fully Anchored In
[Music]
and
as the great poet Stephen Connell says
love is a promise that comes what comes
out be right here and so more so than
any feelings
is this idea that I'm gonna decide every
single morning for the rest of my life
that I'm gonna love you
whether I feel like it whether you're
sick
whether we're broke
whether you've hurt me deeply
every day I will wake up and look across
this room or look at the bed next to me
and say I do
and if you can do that it's game on why
wait
okay if you can't
if you refuse to make that commitment
and her make that commitment don't do it
man you've had a great run it's been fun
you like dating it's a blast
feelings will come and go my brother and
anybody who gives you some sort of
Matrix
do these 10 things or this is the 15
ways to know if she's the one they're
just smelling you so I mean they're
they're selling your snake oil man it's
nonsense and I I think you've
definitely zeroed in a lot on who I am
in that I'm very much a assistance
driven kind of person I do like to hear
it all over you if you're not a coder
yeah man I can hear it all over not
quite but I'm pretty close exactly so
like
okay I'll I'll explain it this way is
the best way I can explain
um
do you know who Dave Ramsey is
oh of course I do okay so I got to you
he's my okay yeah he's my boss right and
he took a couple of uh skydiving this
past summer
there is nothing in my life more
terrifying than Heights for me
I'm talking like I don't like to get on
a ladder I don't like to look over the
edge at a second story like up a set of
stairs dude I've trained with Pro MMA
fight I'm not I've been in active
shooter situation I'm not scared of much
anything I hate heights hate them and so
when he sent the email around saying hey
I'll um I'll pick up the tab we all go
uh skydiving who's in
a couple of my colleagues said I'm out
I'm out and I instantly just went I'm in
and dude I didn't sleep for for however
long I mean I was terrified man but
listen
um it was a spiritual experience for me
and I know that sounds like lame but
here's what it was for me
it showed me this this adventure I had
been on in my marriage where for so many
years I tried to love harder by clamping
down like holding on tighter
holding on to my wife into our values
into our rules into the way things are
in our house and how's our house gonna
and it was this constant revision
are we aligned are we on this thing or
and then I jumped out of that plane man
and you just let go
and I had to lean in and Trust the dude
behind me this former Navy SEAL who had
a vested interest in landing safely also
dude it was a total abandonment total
trust like I've never experienced I
gotta trust this guy or I'm dead
gotta do what he says or I'm dead
and it was one of those magic my wife
came with us actually and on our when I
got home and we were just talking about
it
we both had a conversation about
oh that's belief is not trying to get
all the rules right it's letting go
that's love it's not trying to take you
it's not trying to suffocate my wife and
my family and my kids it's letting go
and when I let go then she feels safe
enough to be so deeply rooted
in our marriage that she feels safe and
when she feels safe she can breathe when
she can breathe and also see what I'm
saying so it's good I think I do it's
gonna be exactly opposite of your
impulse
I want to control every variable I want
to make sure every T is crossed every
eye is dotted before we do this other
thing because once we do this thing
there's no coming back I'll tell you
right now dude
you're gonna cross that line and be like
what happened
yeah right the thing that you can
control on this side of of that
experience is
come what come I will be right here
and I'll spend the rest of my life
trying to meet your needs
will you my love spend the rest of your
life
helping me meet mine
and that's the dance
I think that's very well but
um yeah
and I would do anything to have your way
of seeing the World by the way I'm kind
of a chaotic mess so
um you will bring immense value to your
marriage by your hopefully you're
marrying somebody that's gonna drag you
out dancing and you are going to be the
guy that's like how about we pay the
light bill too like I hopefully that
hopefully that's how you all work right
you have uh an incredible value to
relationships I need people like you for
real
um if it wasn't for my wife I would have
an awesome podcast and be homeless at
the same time so you have immense value
but when it comes to this one decision
I'm in I'm in I'm in come what come I'll
be here
and my feelings are going to be a part
of the the signal system but they are
not going to be the direction the
direction is
comma come I'll be right here
I'm not going anywhere that's love and I
hate to say this so crassly but my
brother
loves a choice every day for the rest of
your life